welcome to the fourth lecture
of 6006. um today
we are going to be talking about hashing
last lecture
on tuesday um professor solomon was
talking about
uh set data structures right storing
things
so that you can query items by
their key right by what they
intrinsically are
versus what professor domain was talking
about last week which was sequence data
structures where
we impose an external order on these
items
and we want you to maintain those but
i'm not i don't really
i'm not supporting operations where i'm
looking stuff up based on what they are
right that's what the set interface is
for right so we're going to be talking a
little bit more about the set
interface today so last on tuesday
you saw two ways of implementing the set
interface
right one using just a unsorted array
just
i threw these things in an array and i
could do a linear scan of my items
to support basically any of these
operations it's a little exercise you
can go through
i think they show it to you in the
recitation notes but if you'd like to
implement it
for yourself that's fine uh in and then
we saw a slightly better data structure
at least for the find operations
can i look something up whether this key
is in my
uh set interface we can do that faster
we can do that in log n time
with a build overhead that's about n log
n right because we showed you three ways
to sort
two of them were n squared one of them
was n log n
which is as good as we showed you how to
do yesterday
so the question then becomes can i build
that data structure faster that'll be a
subject of next week's
thursday lecture but this week we're
going to concentrate on
this static find right right we got log
n which is an exponential improvement
over
linear right
but the question here now becomes can i
do faster than log n time
and what we're going to do at the first
part of this lecture is show you that no
you what's up what no
okay that you can't do faster than log n
time in the caveat that we are in a
slightly more restricted model of
computation
that we were then what we introduced to
you a couple weeks ago
and then so if we're not in that that
more constrained model of computation we
can actually do faster
right and doing faster is i mean log n
is already pretty good
right log n is not going to be larger
than like
30 for any problem that you're going to
be talk talking about uh in the real
world on real computers
but uh a factor of 30 is still bad
right i would prefer to do faster with
those constant factors when i can
it's not a constant factor it's a
logarithmic factor but you get what i'm
saying
okay so what we're going to do is first
prove that
you can't do faster for for fine does
everyone understand
remember what find key meant right i
have
a key i have a bunch of items that have
keys associated with them
and i want to see if one of the items
that i'm storing
contains a key that is the same as the
one that i searched for right
the item might contain other things but
it in particular has a
search key that i'm maintaining the set
on so that it supports
find operation search operations based
on that key
quickly does that make sense so
there's the find one that we want to
improve and we also want to improve this
insert delete we want to be make this
this data structure dynamic right
because we we might uh
do those operations quite a bit and so
this lecture is about
optimizing those three things okay so
first i'm going to show you that we
can't do faster than log n
for find which is a little weird
okay the model of computation i'm going
to be
proving this lower bound on right i'm
saying that
how i'm going to approach this is i'm
going to say that any
way that i store these the items that
i'm storing in this data structure
for any way i store these things any
algorithm of this certain type
is going to require at least logarithmic
time
that's that's what we're going to try to
prove and the model of computation
that's that's weaker than what we've
been talking about previously
is what i'm going to call the comparison
model
and a comparison model means is that the
items the objects i'm storing i can kind
of think of them as black boxes
i don't get to touch these things except
the only way that i can distinguish
between them
is to say given a
key and an item or two items
i'm i can do a comparison on those keys
right
are these keys the same uh is this key
bigger
than this one is it smaller than this
one those are kind of the only
operations i get to do with them
i don't get to look at what the say if
the keys are numbers i don't get to look
at what number that is
right i just get to take two keys and
compare them and actually
all of the search algorithms that we saw
on tuesday were comparison sort
algorithms right
what you did was you stepped through the
program
at some point you came to a branch and
you looked at
two keys and you branched based on
whether one key was bigger than another
right that was a comparison and then you
moved some stuff around but that was the
general
paradigm those those three sorting
operations uh lived in this comparison
model right you've got
uh you know comparison operations like
are they equal less than greater than
maybe greater than or equal less than or
equal right
generally you have all these operations
that you could do maybe not equal
right but the key thing here
is that there are only two possible
outputs to each of these comparators
right
there's only two things there's there's
only one one
thing that i can branch on it's going to
branch into two different lines right
it's either true
and i do some other computation or it's
false and i'll do
a different set of computation right
that makes sense
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
view a comparison
an algorithm in the comparison model as
what i like to call a decision tree
right so if i specify an algorithm to
you the first thing it's going to do
if i don't compare items at all i'm kind
of screwed because i'll never be able to
tell
if my keys and they're not so i have to
do some comparisons
so you know i'll do some computation you
know maybe i find out the length of the
array and i do some constant time stuff
but at some point i'll do a comparison
and i'll
i'll branch right i'll come to this node
and
if the comparison like maybe a less than
right
if it's true i'm going to go this way in
my computation and if it's false i'm
going to go this way in my computation
right and i'm going to keep doing that
with various comparisons um
sure
until i get down here to some
[Music]
leaf in which i'm i'm not branching
right the internal nodes here are
representing
comparisons but the leaves are
representing i stopped my computation
i'm outputting something does that make
sense
what i'm kind of trying to do i'm kind
of
changing my algorithm to be put in this
kind of graphical way
where i'm branching what my program
could possibly do
based on the comparisons that i do right
i'm not i'm not
actually counting the rest of the work
that the program does
right i'm really only looking at the
comparisons
right because i know that i i'll need to
compare some things
eventually to figure out what my items
are and if that's the only way i can
distinguish items
then i have to do those comparisons to
to find out right does that make sense
all right so what i have is a binary
tree
that's representing the comparisons done
by my algorithm
okay so it starts at one comparison and
then it branches
how many leaves must i have in my tree
what does that question mean right like
in in terms of the program
what's up the number comparison the
number of comparisons no that's the
number of internal nodes that i have
in the algorithm and actually the number
of comparisons that i do in an execution
of the algorithm is just
along a path from here to the to a leaf
right so what do the leaves actually
represent those are represent
outputs right i'm going to output
something here
and yeah the number of i
okay so i need at least
so what is the output to my search
algorithm maybe it's the
an index of an item that contains this
key or maybe
i return the item uh
is the output right the item so the of
the thing i'm storing and i'm storing n
things so i need at least
n outputs right because i need to be
able to return
any of the items that i'm storing based
on a different
search key parameter if it's going to be
correct i actually need one more output
why do i need one more output
if it's not in there right right so
any correct comparison
searching algorithm i've i'm doing some
comparisons to find this thing
needs to have at least
n plus one leaves
right otherwise it can't be correct
because
i could look up the one that i i'm not
returning in that set
and it would never be able to return
that value does that make sense
yeah what's n n is always the num in for
a data structure n is the number of
things stored in that data structure at
that time right so the number of items
in the data structure that's what it
means in all of these tables
any other questions okay so now we get
to the fun part
how many comparisons does this algorithm
have to do
yeah up there what's up
all right your colleague is jumping
ahead for a second but really
i have to do as many comparisons in the
worst case
as the longest route to leaf path
in this tree right because as i'm
executing this algorithm i'll go
you know down this thing always
branching down
and at some point i'll get to a leaf and
in the worst case
if i happen to need to return this
particular output
right then i'll have to walk down the
longest thing
right it's the longest path
so and the longest path is the same as
the height of the tree
okay so the question then becomes what
is the minimum height
of any binary tree that has at least n
plus one leaves
ever understand why we're asking that
question
okay so unrest yeah
why it needs n plus one leads if it's a
correct algorithm it needs to return
it needs to be able to return any of the
n items that i'm storing
or say that the key that i'm looking for
is not there
great question okay so
what is the minimum height of any binary
tree
that has n plus one at least n plus one
leaves
you'll you can solve that uh you can
actually state a recurrence for that and
solve that you're going to do that in
your recitation
but it's log n right like the best you
can do is if this is a balanced
binary tree right so the min
height
is going to be at least
log n height right
right where the min height is
logarithmic right so it's actually theta
right here but but if i just said height
here
i would be lower bounding the height
right if i could have a linear
height right if i just chained
comparisons down
one by one if i was doing a linear
search for example
right all right so this is saying that
if i'm just restricting to comparisons
i have to spend at least logarithmic
time to be able to find
whether this key is in my set right
but i don't want logarithmic time i want
faster
so how can i do that i have one
operation
in my model of computation i presented a
couple weeks ago
that allows me to do faster which allows
me to do something stronger than
comparisons
comparisons have a constant branching
factor
in particular i can i if i do this
operation this constant time operation
i can branch
to two different locations right it's
like an if
kind of situation if or else right
and in fact if i had constant branching
factor for
any constant here
right if i had three or four if it was
bounded by a constant
the height of this tree would still be
bounded by a log base
the constant of that number of leaves
okay so i need in some sense to be able
to branch
a non-constant amount right
so how can i branch a non-constant
amount
this is a little tricky right we had
this really neat
operation in the random access
machine that we could randomly
uh go to any place in memory in constant
time based on a number
right
it was a super powerful thing because
within a single constant time operation
i could go to any space in memory right
that's
that's potentially much larger than
linear branching factor depending on the
size of my model
and the size of my machine right so
that's a very powerful operation can we
use that
to find quicker anyone have any ideas
sure uh we're going to get to hashing in
a second but this is a
simpler concept a concept in hashing
hashing
something you probably are familiar with
already
we've kind of been using it implicitly
in some of our sequence data structure
things
what we're going to do is if i have a
an item that has key 10 okay
i'm going to keep an array and store
that item
10 spaces away from the front of the
array right at
index nine or the tenth index does that
make sense
if i store that item at that location in
memory i can use this
random access to that location
and see if there's something there if
there's something there i return that
item does that make sense
this is what i call a direct access
array
it's really no different than the arrays
that we've been
talking about earlier in the class
we got an array and if i have
an item here with key equals 10
i'll stick it here in the 10th place
now i can only now store one item
with the key 10 in my thing and that's
one of the stipulations we had on our
set data structures right if we tried to
insert something
with the same key as something already
stored there we're going to replace the
item
right that's what the semantics of our
set interface was
but that's okay that's that's that's
satisfying uh the conditions of our send
interface
so if we store it there that's fantastic
how
how
long does it take to find if we have an
item with the the key 10
it takes constant time worst case great
how about inserting or deleting
something
what's what's that again constant time
we've solved all of our problems this is
amazing
okay what's not amazing about this why
don't we just do this all the time
ah i don't know how high the numbers go
right so let's say i'm storing i don't
know
a number associated with the the
three or four hundred of you that are in
this classroom
right but i'm storing your mit ids
how big are those numbers those are like
nine digit numbers
right pretty long numbers so what i
would need to do
in in if i was storing your keys as
uh mit ids i would need an
array that has indices that span the
entire space
of nine digit numbers right that's like
10 to the nine or nine uh
10 to the nine thank you ten to the nine
is the the size of a direct access array
i would have to build to be able to
use this um
[Music]
this technique to to create a direct
access array to search on your mit ids
when there's only really 300 of you in
here
right so 300 or 400 is an n
that's much smaller than the size of the
numbers that i'm trying to store
what i'm going to use as a variable to
to talk about the size of the numbers
i'm storing
i'm going to say u is the maximum size
of any number that i'm storing
okay it's the size of the universe of
space of keys
that i'm storing does that make sense
okay so to
instantiate a direct access array of
that size i have to allocate that amount
of space
and so if that is much bigger than n
then i'm kind of screwed right because
i'm using much more space
and these order operations are bad also
right because essentially
if i am storing these things
uh non-continuously i kind of just have
to scan down
the thing to find the next element for
example
right okay what's your question
a direct access array is a set data
structure that's why it's a set
interface up there so uh
this is uh your colleague is asking
whether
you can use a direct access array to
implement a set i mean a sequence
and actually i think you'll see in your
recitation notes you have code that
can take a set data structure and
implement a sequence data structure and
take a sequence data structure and
implement a set data structure
they just won't necessarily have very
good run time so this direct access
array semantics
is really just good good for these
specific set operations
that make sense yeah what you u is this
the size of the largest key that i'm
allowed to store that makes sense
right and the the direct access array is
supporting
you up to you size keys does that make
sense
okay we're going to move on for a second
so what's that that's the problem right
we
when you largest
key we are we're assuming integers here
right
integer keys right so
in the comparison model we could store
any arbitrary
objects that that supported a comparison
here
we really need to have integer keys or
else we're not going to
be able to use those as addresses right
so
we're making a an assumption on the
inputs that i can only store
integers now i can't store arbitrary
objects
items with keys and in particular i also
need to
this is a subtlety that's in the word
ram model
how can i be assured that these keys can
be looked up in constant time
how does my seat my this little cpu
right it's got some
number of registers it can act upon how
big is those registers
what well so they're they're right now
they're 64 bits but in general they're
w they're the size of your word
on your machine that's how many uh two
to the w is the number of addresses i
can access
so implicitly i'm kind of if i'm going
to be able to use this direct access
array
i need to make sure that the u is
you know less than 2 to the w
right if i want these operations to run
in constant time
right if i have keys that are much
larger than this
i'm going to need to do something else
okay
but this is this is kind of the
assumption in in this class
when we give you like an array of
integers or an array of strings or
something like that on your problem set
or on an exam
right the assumption is unless we give
you a
bounds on the size of those things right
like the number of characters in your
string or the size of the number and
you can assume that those things will
fit in in
one word of memory okay
w is the word size of your machine right
the number of bits that your machine can
do
operations on in constant time
any other questions okay so we have this
problem
we're using way too much space right
when we have a large universe of keys so
how do we get around that problem any
ideas
sure
okay so what your colleague is saying
instead of just storing one value at
each place
maybe store more than one value
if we're using this uh idea right where
i am storing my key at the index of the
key
that's getting around the us having to
have unique keys
in our data structure it's not getting
around this
space usage problem does that make sense
we will end up storing multiple things
at indices
but there's an another trick that i'm
looking for right now
right we have a lot of space that we
would need to allocate for this data
structure
what's an alternative
instead of allocating a lot of space we
allocate
less space right let's allocate less
space all right so
we have a really like
this is our space of keys right you
right
but instead i want to store those things
in a direct access array of maybe size
n right something like
the order of the things that i'm going
to be storing i'm going to relax that
and say
we're going to make this a length m
that's
you know around the size of the things
i'm storing
okay and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to try to map this space of keys
this large space of keys from like zero
to u minus one or something like that
right down to a range that's
zero to m minus one okay
right i'm gonna want a function this is
what i'm going to call h
which maps
this range down to a smaller range
does that make sense i'm gonna have some
function that takes that large space of
keys
sticks them down here okay
and instead of storing at an index
of the key i'm going to put the key
through this function
the key space into a compressed space
and store it at that index location
does that make sense sure
oh your colleague is comes comes up with
the
the question i was going to ask right
away which was
what's the problem here the problem is
it's the potential
that we might be story have to store
more than one thing
at the same index location right
if i have a function that matches this
big space
down to this small space
i gotta have multiple of these things
going to the same places here right it's
got a
it can't be injective right
but just based on pigeonhole principle i
have more of these things
at least two of them have to go to
something over here in fact
if i have say u is bigger than n squared
for example
right there for any function i give you
that maps this large space down to the
small space
n of these things will map to the same
place
right so if i choose a bad function here
then i'll have to store n things at the
same index location and if i go there
i have to kind of check to see whether
any of those are the things that i'm
looking for i haven't gained anything
right i really want a hash function that
will evenly distribute
keys over this space
right does that make sense
but we have a problem here if we need to
store multiple things
at a given location in memory
can't do that i have one thing i can put
there so i have two
options on how to deal what what i call
collisions
right if i have two items here like
a and b these are different keys right
in my
universe of space but it's possible
that they both map down to some
hash that has the same value
right so where do i if i if i first hash
a and a is i put put a there
where do i put b
there are kind of two options um
is the second data structure a linked
list so that
um it can store me okay so what your
colleague was saying
can i store this one as a linked list
and then i can just insert
a guy right next to where it was
what's the problem there is linked lists
are linked lists good with
direct accessing by an index
no they're terrible with get at and set
at right they take linear time there
right so really the whole point of
direct access array is that there is an
array underneath
and i can do this index from arithmetic
and go down to the next thing
so i really don't want to replace a
linked list as this data structure
yeah what's up
we can make it really unlikely sure
i don't know what likely means because
i'm giving you a hash function one hash
function
and i don't know what the inputs are
yeah
okay right so there are actually two
solutions here one is
i i maybe if i choose m to be larger
than n
right there's going to be extra space in
here
i'll just stick it somewhere else in the
existing array
right how i find an open space is a
little complicated
but this is a technique
called open addressing which is much
more common than the technique we're
going to be talking about today
in implementations python uses an open
addressing scheme
which is essentially find another place
in the array to to put this
collision but it's open addressing is
notoriously difficult to analyze so
we're not going to do that in this class
there's a much easier technique
that we have an implementation for you
in the recitation handouts
it's what your colleague up here i can't
find him over there was saying
was instead of storing it somewhere else
in the existing
direct access array down here which we
usually call the hash table
right instead of storing it
somewhere else in that hash table we'll
instead add that key
store a pointer to another data
structure
right some other data structure that can
store a bunch of things just
like any sequence data structure like a
dynamic array or a linked list or
anything right
all i need to do is be able to stick a
bunch of things on there
uh when there are collisions and then
when i go up to look for that thing
i'll just look through all of the things
in that
data structure and see if my key exists
does that make sense
now we want to make sure that those
additional data structure
structures which i'll call chains right
we want to make sure that those chains
are short right they don't i don't want
them to be long
right so what i'm going to do is when i
have this collision here instead i'll
have a pointer to some
i don't know maybe make it a dynamic
array or a linked list or something like
that
and i'll put a here and i'll put b here
and then later
when i look up key k right
or look up key a or b let's look up key
b
i'll go to this hashed value here
i'll put it through the hash function
i'll go to this index i'll go to the
data structure the chain associated with
that index
and i'll look at all of these items i'm
just going to do a linear find i'm going
to look
i could put any data structure here but
i'm going to look at this one
see if it's b it's not b look at this
one
it is b i return yes does that make
sense this is an idea called chaining
i can put anything i want there commonly
we talk about
putting a linked list there but you can
put
you know a dynamic array there you can
put a
sorted array there to make it easier to
check whether the key is there
you can put anything you want there the
point of this lecture
is going to try to show that there's a
choice of hash function i can make
that make sure that these chains are
small
that it really doesn't matter how i
store them there right
because i can just i have i have time if
there's a constant number of things
stored there
i can just look at all of them and do
whatever i want
and still get constant time yeah so
and like let's just say like for some
reason the number of things
is that most of them get like multiple
yeah so what your your colleague is
saying is kind of at initialization what
is stored here
right initially it points to an empty
data structure right
i'm just going to initialize all of
these things to have now you get some
overhead here right we're paying
something for this some extra space in
having pointer and another data
structure at all of these things
or you could have the semantics where if
i only have one thing here
i'm going to store that thing at this
location but if i have multiple it
points to a data structure
these are kind of complicated you know
implementation details but you get the
basic idea
right if i just have a zero size data
structure at all of these things
i'm still going to have a constant
factor overhead
right it's still going to be a linear
size data structure as long as
m is linear in n does that make sense
okay so how do we pick a good hash
function
i already told you that any fixed hash
function i give you
is going to experience collisions and if
u
is large right
then there is the possibility that i for
some input all of the things in my set
go
directly to the same hashed index value
so that ain't great let's ignore that
for a second what's the easiest way
to get down from this large space of
keys down to a small one
what's the easiest thing you could do
yeah modulus
great this is called the division method
okay
and what it's the function is is
essentially it's going to take a key
and it's going to set it equal to b k
mod
m okay i'm going to take something of a
large space
i'm going to mod it so that it kind of
just wraps around
right
perfectly valid thing to do it satisfies
what we're
doing in a hash table and if my keys are
completely uniformly distributed
ran like if if when i use my hash
function
all of the keys here are uniformly
distributed over this
this larger space then actually this
isn't a
such a bad thing right but that's
imposing
some kind of distribution requirements
on the type of inputs i'm allowed to use
with this hash function for it to be of
have good performance
right but this plus a little bit of
extra you know mixing and bit
manipulation
is essentially what python does
it essentially all it does is kind of
jumbles up that key
for some fixed amount of jumbling
and then mods it m and sticks it there
but there are some it's it's hard-coded
in the the python
library what this hash function is and
so there exists
some sequences of inserts
into a hash table in python which
will be really bad in terms of
performance because these
these chain lengths or the amount number
of collisions that i'll get at a single
hash
is going to be large right but they do
that for other reasons they want a
deterministic hash function they want
something that i do the program
again it's going to do the same thing
underneath right
but sometimes python gets it wrong but
if your data
that you're storing is sufficiently
uncorrelated to the hash function that
they've chosen
which usually it is this is a pretty
good performance
okay but this is not a uh
practical class well it is a practical
class but
one of the things that we are uh that's
the emphasis of this class
is making sure we can prove that this is
good in theory as well
right i don't want to know that
sometimes this will be good
i really want to know that if i choose
if i if i make this data structure and i
put some inputs on it i want a running
time
that is independent on what inputs i
decided to use
independent of what keys i decided to
store does that make sense
right in some sense i want but it's
impossible for me to pick a fixed hash
function
that will achieve this right because i
just told you that if u is large
right this is if u is large
then there exists inputs that map
everything to one place
so i feel i'm screwed right i can't
there's no way to solve this problem
that's true if i want a deterministic
hash function right
i want the thing to be repeatable to do
the same thing over and over again
for any set of inputs what can i do
instead
weaken my notion of what constant time
is to do better
okay use a non-deterministic what does
not what does non-deterministic mean
right
it means don't choose a hash function
up front choose one randomly later
right so have the user they pick
whatever inputs they're gonna do and
then i'm gonna pick a hash function
randomly they don't know which hash
function i'm gonna pick so it's hard for
them
to give me an input that's bad right
okay so how do i'm going to choose a
random hash function
how do i choose a random can i choose a
a hash function from the
space of all hash functions what is the
space of all hash functions of this form
right for every one of these values i
give a value in here
right that would be a completely like i
choose
for each one of these independently
random number between this range
how many such hash functions are there
m m to the this number
that's a lot of things right so i can't
do that
what i can do is fix a family of hash
functions where if i choose
one from randomly i get good performance
and so the hash function i'm going to
use
and we're going to spend the rest of the
time on
is what i call a universal hash function
it has it satisfies what we call a
universal
hash property so universal
hash function and
this is a little bit of a weird
nomenclature because
i'm defining this to you as the
universal hash function
but actually universal is a uh you know
a descriptor
right there exists many universal hash
functions
this just happens to be an example of
one of them okay
so the hash function uh or
really
right so we're gonna
so here's the hash function
it doesn't look actually all that
different
goodness gracious how many parentheses
are there
mod p mod
m okay so it's kind of doing the same
thing
as what's happening up here right
but before modding by m i'm
multiplying it by a number i'm adding a
number
i'm taking it mod another number and
then i'm modding by m
okay this is a little weird and not only
that this is still a fixed hash function
i don't want that i want to generalize
this to be a family of hash functions
which are this h a
b k
for some random choice
of a b
in this larger range
all right this is a lot of
notation here essentially what this is
saying is
i have a hash family okay it's
parameterized by the length of my hash
function
and some fixed large random prime that's
bigger than u
just i'm going to pick some large prime
number
okay and that's going to be fixed when i
make the hash
table okay
and then when i instantiate the hash
table i'm going to choose randomly one
of these things
by choosing a random a and a random b
from this range
does that make sense
this is a not equal to zero right if i
had zero here
i kind of lose the key information and
that's no good
does this make sense so what this is do
is multiplying this key by some random
number
adding some random number modding by
this prime
and then modding by the size of my thing
okay so it's doing a bunch of jumbling
and there's some randomness involved
here i'm choosing the hash function by
choosing
an a b randomly from this thing so when
i start up my program
right i'm going to instantiate this
thing with some random a
and b not deterministically right the
user
when they're using this thing doesn't
know which a and b i picked
right so it's really hard for them to
give me a bad example
right and this universal hash function
this universal hash family shall we say
really this is a family of functions and
i'm choosing one
randomly within that family
is universal and universality
says that what is it what is the
property of universality
it means that the probability by
choosing
a hash function from this hash family
that
a certain key collides
with another key
is less than or equal to one over m
for all any
uh different two keys
in my universe
does that make sense so if i
basically this thing has the property
that if i randomly pick or if i
for any two keys right that i pick
in my universe space if i randomly
choose a hash function
the probability that these things
collide is less than
one over m why is that good this is in
some sense a measure
of how well distributed these things are
i want these things to collide with one
over
m probability so that these things
don't collide very likely it's not very
likely for these things to collide does
that make sense
so we won't prove that this hash family
satisfies this universality property
you'll do that no four six but we can
use
this result to show that if we use a
universal ha
this universal hash family that
the length of our change chains
is expected to be constant length
okay so we're going to use this property
to prove that okay
how do we prove that we're going to do a
little probability
okay so how are we going to prove that
i'm going to define a random variable an
indicator random variable does anyone
remember what an indicator random
variable is
yeah it's a it's a variable that with
some
amount of probability is one and one
minus that probability is zero
right so i'm going to define this
indicator
random variable i x i j
is a random variable over my choice
over choice of a hash function
in my hash family and what does this
mean
it means x i j equals one
if hash
ki
equals hkj these things collide
right and zero otherwise
okay so i'm choosing randomly over this
hash family
if for two keys
i and j key i and key j if these things
collide
that's going to be one if they don't
then it's zero
okay then how can we write a formula
for the length of a a chain in this
model right so the size of a chain
right
or let's put it here
the size of the chain
at i
right at i in my hash table
is going to equal i'm going to call that
the random variable x
i that's going to equal the sum over
j equals 0 to
is it over i think u minus 1
of summation or
sorry of x i j
right so basically if i fix
this uh this location i
right
if i fix this location i this is where
this key goes
right so i'm looking at sorry this is
the size of
chain at h of
k i sorry so i look at wherever
k i goes is hashed right and i see how
many things collide with it
right i'm just summing over all of these
things right
because this is one if there's a
collision and zero if there's not
does that make sense so this is the size
of the chain
at the index location mapped to by
ki okay
so here's where your probability comes
in
what's the expected value of this chain
length over my random choice
okay expected value over choosing
a hash function from this universal hash
family
of this chain length
well that's just i can put in my
definition here that's the expected
value
of the summation over
j of x i j
what do i know about expectations and
summations
if these variables are independent from
each other
say say what
linearity of expectation right basically
the
expectation of the sum of these
independent random variables is the same
as the summation of their expectations
right so this is equal to the summation
over
j of the expectations of these
individual ones
okay
one of these j's is the same as i
right j j loops over all of the things
from zero
to u minus one right one of them is i
right so when x h i
is h j what is
what is the expected value that they
collide
one right so i'm going to refactor this
as being
this where j does not equal i
plus one are people okay with that
because if i equals
if if if j and i are equal they
definitely collide right they're the
same key
right so i'm expected to have one guy
there
which was the original key x i right
but otherwise we can use this universal
property
right that says if they're not
equal and they collide which is exactly
this case
right the probability that that happens
is 1 over m right and since it's
an indicator random variable the
expectation is
their outcomes times their probabilities
right so 1 times that probability
plus 0 times 1 minus that probability
right which is just
1 over m right so now we get
the summation of one over m
for j not equal to i
plus one
oh and this sorry i did this wrong
this isn't u this is n we're storing n
keys right okay
so now i'm looping over j this over all
of those things
how many things are there and minus one
things right
so this should equal one plus n
minus one over m okay so that's what
universality gives us so as long as we
choose
m to be like larger than n
or at least linear in n then we're
expected
to have our chain lengths be constant
right because this thing becomes a
constant
if m is at least order n does that make
sense
okay the last thing i'm going to leave
you with is how do we make this thing
dynamic
if we're growing the number of things
we're storing in this thing
it's possible that as we grow n for a
fixed m
this thing will stop being m will stop
being linear in n
right well then all we have to do is if
we get
too far we rebuild the entire thing
the entire hash table with the new m
right just like we did with a
dynamic array and you can prove we're
not going to do that here
but you can prove that you won't do that
operation too
often if you're resizing in the right
way
and so you just rebuild completely after
a certain number of operations okay so
that's hashing
next week we're going to be talking
about doing a faster sort